what is up everybody
know your uh display is not done it's
just back to
the second part of the raspberry pi
tutorial series here what we're going to
be doing is talking about
how to download um an
operating system onto your raspberry pi
so you can begin actually
using your raspberry pi there are a lot
of options
for an operating system but for now
we're just gonna
do start with the most basic and easy
way to do this
so the best thing that you can do now um
i'm sure there's somebody out there
that's had a video on this
but if you've visited the raspberry pi
website
uh anytime recently uh you'll see they
actually have this
noobs uh thing which i've never heard
before i think that's the cutest thing
in the world
new out of box software for noobs anyway
i think it's a great name so anyway you
can download this um
from the raspberry pi downloads and what
this is going to be
is it's going to solve any sort of like
instead of having to like put the image
on the disk and all this kind of stuff
it's going to do that for you
so you can just download this and then
on your first
startup you'll be presented with a list
of operating systems for you to choose
from
and then it'll install the operating
systems
and like you know with the image and all
that itself so it's actually really cool
and the other cool thing you can do is
just by holding shift you can change the
operating system that's going to delete
everything on your old operating system
but
you can kind of switch between them and
see which one you like without
really doing anything so it's awesome um
you you're gonna need you know to do it
this way you'll need at least a four
gigabyte or larger sd card in this case
i've got an
eight and um
really that's about it so let's go ahead
and download this you can use this stuff
honestly i'm just gonna put this out
there someone can probably really kill
me
but uh you can use this to check some
and make sure your download is like a
worthy download but
if it's not and like something has gone
awry
you'll find out anyways so why waste
time doing this i don't know it's pretty
quick i mean
you put this on the on the card i mean
it doesn't take very long to transfer it
and if stuff doesn't work then try it
again because that's what happens if the
checksum fails
you have to re-download it so i don't
know
anyway so we visited here and
uh now the noobs thing is downloading
it's 1.1 gigabytes so
it's going to take a while i have
basically no bandwidth because i run
like two servers so um
yeah it's probably gonna take a while so
anyway let me pause this
and uh we'll resume once it's done
downloading
oh by the way i forgot to mention uh
while you're while you are downloading
it the next thing that you want to do
is download where is it i thought they
would write it up on here but i don't
see it
we want to download the uh sd card
formatter and here we go here's a link
for it so when you're in the slash
downloads
uh we next thing we want to do is format
the sd card so we'll click on that it's
going to take us to this the downloads
for this sd formatter
and i don't know too much about sd cards
but what it's going to do is format it
i don't know in the proper format for
running an operating system off of it
someone else can say exactly how this
works or why you have to use this but
anyway you do so you know whatever
computer you're on right now
uh download the proper version and once
you've done
that i'll show you what you'll arrive
with
okay so when you run the program this
will be what you've got you'll have
you know some information up here this
will be about your card what drive it's
in
volume label the only thing you really
need to do at this point before you hit
format is go into your options
and for format size adjustment go ahead
and turn that on hit ok
and hit format and hit okay
of course we're not going to remove it
while we're formatting it
okay so anyway now the format is
complete
uh gives you some information and we'll
go ahead
and exit so now the next thing
uh once you've downloaded the noobs
software and you are
um or you've already formatted your sd
card the next thing we want to do is
actually go into our sd card
and so here is my sd card i just brought
it up another window
and you just want to click and drag
basically this stuff right on in there
and i thought it's going to take a
little bit because it's
1.1 gigs so let me go ahead and pause
while it's doing that
and actually i just thought about a
couple things i'll mention once we get
this done i'm actually probably going to
have to come off the screen recorder
and go back to the handheld because the
rest of stuff will be
on the raspberry pi as we're installing
it so i guess we'll
do the rest by camera but i would just
mention
this is the first time like i've ever
encountered something like this
honestly but the little sd card has like
a slider on the side that locks it from
having data
like overwritten and a lot of the
inserts at least on my computer when i
was doing this
it kept telling me it was locked i would
unlock it slip it in and be like oh it's
locked again
and it turned out that every time i was
pushing it in
the slider on the side was locking
right because it needs to go down to
lock and that's what something was
rubbing up against it and locking it
so that was really irritating so if you
have that problem what you do is just
take a piece of scotch tape and like
unlock it and just put the tape over the
lock so it'll make the fit
a little tighter than normal
but that'll stop it from getting locked
just thought i'd say that i never had
the problem maybe no one else will have
this issue
but uh that was really irritating so
that's that
all right guys looks like this is about
to be over so
once you're done with the transfer
you'll go ahead and pull out the sd card
and everything for our
film uh coming up next is gonna have to
be live again
uh because we'll be dealing with the
physical pie um
so anyway as always thank you for
watching thank you for your support your
subscriptions
and until next time